[Music]
the parents of a student from an ICU who
died in a boxing fight filed
a lawsuit that such health to cristian
cásseres with his brief information on
news now in spanish nate's parents
in valencia ask him to help ovi the
capaeg ma fraternity  and the
university educational system that did not
fulfill their responsibility to
keep you safe they clarify that they
want to make sure that no other
family goes through this
the
clark county school district police department together with
local law enforcement authorities are
working on tracking down drivers who
drive recklessly in
school zones be on the lookout for those who
drive too fast near
schools the last time they did this they
hid over 350 drivers
and changing the subject we will tell you that there
will be tougher penalties for
those seen with
fires  illegal artificial
the county commission approved fines more c  For
these incidents, the first time it will be
500 dollars, about a thousand dollars for the
second, if the fires represent
less than 100 pounds, the fines could
reach 10 thousand dollars, so
be very careful and we reach the
navel of the week, we will have a long day
sunny with a clear sky
temperatures will reach 60
degrees by the afternoon temperatures
will rise a bit but will drop again
over the next few days I'm cristian
casseres with his short
spanish neon news good day
[Music]